today we are talking about Instagram and
uh the past year and a half I guess I've
had a love-hate relationship with
Instagram and we're gonna dive in this
is a really important one instagram
growing and serving your community and
I'm going to talk about my plan and then
how you can win with content and win
with Community as well if you're taking
Instagram seriously this year here's one
of the things that has really been
frustrating for the past year and a half
is that the reach is down organic reach
on Instagram has been dropping and I
still love YouTube YouTube is still my
number one but I like having a number
two for the short form like where do you
put your short form content and there's
Instagram and Tick Tock and Twitter and
Linkedin and snap and all the other
platforms but the organic reach has been
dropping this is a quote from garyvee
from two years ago if you want to go
watch his video but Instagram's organic
reach is finished so just as we figured
it out it's over it's over it might be a
little bit hyperbolic to exaggerate a
little bit I wouldn't say it's over but
it is harder to win compared to before
and everybody in my circle is seeing
their reach go down especially over the
past six months or so so when that
starts to happen it's like okay am I
doing something wrong am I on the wrong
platform how do I how do I fix this so
this is what's guided a lot of my
thinking especially the past six months
the second is that growth is down and so
this is a comparison of Instagram to
tick tock for me
so it's May 2022 as we're recording this
this is my growth on Instagram versus
Tick Tock now Instagram I didn't really
take seriously until about 2019 so just
as garyvee is saying uh it's over it's
when I started taking it seriously and
that's where we had our biggest jump I
had an account back in 2016 but wasn't
really doing much with it and you can
see we had a big jump and it's been kind
of this slow upward growth meanwhile
Tick Tock has been growing for us at an
incredible rate with very little effort
and the effort I mean here is that we're
still posting a lot of content there but
Instagram has been my number one for
short form so it's been YouTube
Instagram
Tick Tock has been you know the past
year or so and in looking at the numbers
like holy cow we're getting so much more
incredible growth off of tick tock and
so I want to talk Tick Tock a little bit
today as well I'm not going to dive deep
into Tick Tock strategies that can be a
whole other session if you want to do it
but it's easier to grow and it's now
becoming a place for Education as well
so if you can see yeah I see the
difference so Mary saying geometric
progression with Tick Tock yeah the
other really cool thing about Tick Tock
that is that is uh interesting is
yesterday they just announced a revenue
share program so one of the main reasons
why YouTube has been so big for so long
is they share their revenue where the
other platforms really suck at sharing
Revenue so as of yesterday they launched
a new program it's coming out in June
and they're going to be given a 50 50
split a little worse than YouTube but
still decent off of ads that show up in
front of your content right now to
qualify you have to have over a hundred
thousand followers uh but that honestly
should be an achievable goal for you
guys
you know for what you want to do for the
people you want to serve for the message
you want to put out there to the world
you've got a big message and and we
should be aiming towards having a bigger
following it doesn't mean you have to
have 10 million followers to be able to
do it but a hundred thousand followers
is an achievable goal and it's likely
going to just go down as they expand the
program so once you can start making
money on it as well it makes it a lot
more appealing to a lot of people so my
plan
has now shifted as of May 2022 where
Tick Tock has become my number two so
YouTube is still by far number one it's
not even close but after YouTube it goes
Tick Tock for me and then Instagram
instead of flipping it the good news is
a lot of The Tick Tock strategies you
can apply to Instagram so a lot of the
short form content you can go to both so
what we used to be doing was taking our
Instagram content and then that becomes
our hub for short form and then that
goes everywhere so we'll make a tick
tock post we'll make a cartoon we'll
make a video we'll make a quote and then
that goes to tick tock and Linkedin and
Twitter and snap and all the other
places
so YouTube was long form Hub Instagram
was short form Hub and then whatever
goes to Instagram goes to the other
places
as of last week we're switching it it's
YouTube first still
Tick Tock as a secondary home and then
from Tick Tock we take the best
performing content and put it to the
other platforms
and so I want to start to at least gear
your mind towards it because a lot of
the strategies that apply for tick tock
for the content you can apply for
Instagram as well so just a shift this
has been a dramatic shift for me
um it's been coming you know it's been a
year and a half in the making especially
the past six months but this is now the
new plan for my content going forward
for anybody who's like oh my gosh I was
just learning Instagram I'm not going to
talk about Tick Tock and it's
overwhelming and like what am I supposed
to do you know this is part of the game
yeah and this is part of this is part of
my job with mover makers as well is to
show you not just what has worked but
what is working and what will work so
even the move from Facebook to Discord
might have been a little painful for
some people it's like oh I gotta learn
Discord I've never used it before how
does this app work but this is part of
the game because people are not if
you're still using Facebook pages it's
it's a it's the dinosaur and it's dying
off versus Discord which is vibrant and
active and can be used to grow your
business and so in a similar way not
that not that Instagram is dying but but
good to know that this is the next thing
coming up and it's it's not just in the
future five years away it's right here
right now and so part of my job is to
help guide and push and move you to the
places where you can have the biggest
impact because that's what we're trying
to do right and so even something like
YouTube I'm not I'm not obsessed over
YouTube it just happens to be the best
place to get the message out and you
guys have a big message that people need
so let's talk about how to win with
content so when you hear me talk about
my strategy uh you might think oh is
Instagram dead
and and there's a lot of content people
saying is Instagram dead up there is not
dead you just have to shift
you just have to shift the type of
content that you're making to give
yourself the best chance of winning so
this was a really great I don't know if
you guys follow Adam Missouri or not but
he's the CEO of Twitter and he had a
post that he put out last year which was
really insightful as to where the
direction of Instagram is going and how
you can win so one of the big quotes
that he said was Instagram is no longer
a photo sharing app
where if you won on pictures
you're seeing a huge drop in engagement
especially the last six months
a lot of our our cartoons right saw a
huge drop in engagement in reach
Instagram is not promoting pictures as
much anymore oh Rebecca is drawing all
over my slides
we drawing Rebecca how do I don't even
know how to take that off but okay
Rebecca's adding some artwork we got
three green lines to our slides we love
you uh so I thought what I would do is
also even watch this video together
because there's a couple things in here
that I think would be
um really helpful to watch so if I load
up Adam's video here there's a couple
things I want to take note start sharing
more about what we're currently working
on internally at Instagram just to give
you a sense of what's coming before it
comes right so again this is the CEO of
Instagram talking about what they're
currently working on and giving you a
heads up before it comes right so this
was
how do we I don't know how to take this
off with Rebecca's three lines anyway
we'll figure that out
um before it comes so this is July sorry
end of June 2021. right now we are
trying to build new experiences
primarily in four areas the first is
creators and I've talked a lot about
creators and trying to help them make a
living and this has to do with the shift
in power from institutions to
individuals across Industries the second
is video video is driving an immense
amount of growth online from all the
major platforms right now and it's one
that I think we need to lean into more
and I'm gonna actually talk about that
more in a minute the third is shopping
now the pandemic shifted or accelerated
the shift of Commerce from offline to
online by a number of years and we're
trying to lean into that trend and the
fourth is messaging how people connect
with their close friends has changed a
lot over the last five years or so and
has moved primarily to messaging away
from
what's interesting here he doesn't talk
a lot about messaging besides this one
point but he says people are moving
towards messaging and right here away
from feeds and stories
so we're gonna he's gonna go in about
video but Instagram one of the biggest
benefits of Instagram is a messaging
platform
the big advantage of Instagram versus a
tech talk is you can message people who
are not following you so a lot of
activity on Instagram is going down in
the DMS and we'll talk about a messaging
strategy later on today but
the theme of this was Instagram growth
and community that was the name of it
and so having a solid messaging strategy
is a great way for you to win build
connections build customers build
following Etc but it's interesting to
hear him say that a lot of people now on
Instagram are spending their time not
consuming away from the feed and the
stories and instead turn into messaging
feed and stories products but today I
actually want to talk a bit more about
video and I want to start by saying
we're no longer a photo share so that
was it like we're no longer a photo
sharing app and this got a lot of people
really upset it's got a lot of people
who built their brand off of Instagram
photos uh you see some of the comments
here
uh you know that sucks we love pictures
why won't Instagram work for having real
customer service uh Instagram is never
going to have what Tick Tock has in
terms of video algorithm Etc it's like
people are really upset
so Instagram is no longer a photo
sharing app so if you look at your
engagement I don't know if you've been
how long you've been on Instagram but
the engagement on your pictures and the
reach on your pictures versus the videos
has dropped dramatically
we got an important topic to talk about
today how to accelerate the growth of
your movement I'm excited let's dive
into it so the fast passive Freedom this
is again inbuilt to serve
you want to think about the social media
accounts where you're going to live on
and so you think about Instagram you
think about LinkedIn think about Twitter
YouTube uh Facebook right you think
about your main social media accounts
you start by having just the account you
create a professional picture bio and
content right in all of any social media
Network you're going to have the option
to add a picture bio and content and now
gear your picture and your bio towards
your ideal customer what I want you
thinking of if my ideal customer landed
on my page if you're looking at
Instagram right if your ideal client
landed on your Instagram page what they
want to call you what they want to work
with you what they want to potentially
hire you is there enough on there that
makes you think this person knows what
they're talking about they are the
expert they can help me I need to reach
out right so this is what we want to be
doing across all of our social accounts
what's the picture you're going to use
what's your bio that you're going to add
and what content you're going to put up
a lot of times there's inconsistencies
across different platforms there's no
real thought or care consideration to it
make a picture that's a headshot I want
you zoomed in not a full body shot
unless you're in Fitness
maybe there's a case right to see the
whole body but even then people resonate
with the face I want people to recognize
you instantly and so have a same picture
across all your social media accounts
and then again a buyer that speaks to to
your ideal client my my idea is I want
people to come look at your account and
then say I want to work with this person
next we're going to create 10 pieces of
content and that's it so what do you
actually make the 10 pieces of
I laid out in in the book we'll go over
super quickly here it starts with number
one your who right so what's your most
important core value why tell me where
it comes from tell me why it's so
important to you show me why you care
like this is this is how you stand out
versus most people most people's
accounts are boring most companies
accounts are super boring most people
are saying the exact same thing and so
don't make it look like a resume you're
who it's your most important core value
if I'm making a a post about believe it
should it should ooze
confidence and and energy and
awesomeness right and from the heart so
what is your most important core value
and then make an emotional piece of
content that could be a video or could
be written form just something that if I
read it I'm gonna feel that same thing
I'm gonna feel believed by reading your
belief post two is explain your why so
tell me why you're doing what you're
doing tell me your pain that you went
through and tell me how it led to your
purpose right all the stuff that we're
talking about in the book
talk to me about your darkest moment and
how you came out of it
people don't want to learn from the
perfect person people don't want to
learn from the person who looks like
they have it all figured out because it
makes people feel like well they're
perfect I can't be like that I need to
know that you went through the same
thing I went through
that is the thing that will make people
connect to you and so I need to see a
post talking about your why right and
this this format
can be it could be nine YouTube or ten
YouTube videos it could be 10 Instagram
posts 10 LinkedIn posts 10 tweets right
I just need to have content there so
it's not a debt account with just a face
and a bio
and then three is give me your how give
me an overview of your recipe for
success we talk about in the book where
basically how did you get out of the
problem that you were in and how can you
then use that as a tool to teach other
people how they can get out of it as
well that should be one post one of the
things that a lot of people struggle
with when they're creating content is
they're all over the map you wanna you
have so much in your head and you want
to say so many things but then when you
look at a post it's it's a mix of 18
different messages tighten it down Focus
one key thought per post make me feel
one thing if you make me feel ten things
I don't know what to do next right one
key thing per post so you're who your
why your how are three are the ten
toasts I want to see in your Mason 10
pack of content treat it like you're
brochure this is your brochure this is
your flyer this is you talking about
what you're doing and showcasing that
you are an expert because if I'm coming
to your page your profile with a problem
one that you know that you can solve I
need to feel like you are the person to
help me four to six is your recipe
breakdown so how you got out of it
teach me
so the first three posts are more
inspiring more motivational more you
understand me you know what I'm going
through because you've been through it
as well right it connects with me on a
human level your next three are now
going to be you teaching me something
so specifically what did you do or what
can I do to help me get out of the
problem that you know how to solve and
that's three different posts if you can
mix it up between if I'm taking
Instagram if you make it up between
pictures videos uh fire captions awesome
same thing for LinkedIn
pictures videos fire caption if you're
doing Pinterest you have an amazing
picture but write some awesome caption
step seven is results I want to see your
results I want to see uh your client
results of people who you've helped show
me their results so now if you think
about this Arc of a story we're telling
our first three are these emotional
pieces that makes me connect to you as a
human our next three is telling me
exactly what I need to do to get out of
the hole that I'm in right step by step
and don't worry like nobody's gonna take
that thing and just run with it and
crush it people are afraid to give up
their secrets you need to Showcase that
you are an expert and you know what
you're talking about so don't be afraid
about giving them a high level step one
do this and then results so you're
showing me
uh what happened tell me again your
story somebody else's story we're taking
people on a journey on an arc so that
we're likely way more likely to convert
people to want to hire us want to work
with us eight nine now show me more
examples so showing me again more
specifics take me on a journey of of you
or people you've helped dive deeper if
you haven't helped anybody yet give me a
hypothetical example right show me who
you would be helping uh hypothetical of
a mom who has you know these scenarios
or a dad like this or an entrepreneur
just starting off right
um I could if it were me and I was just
getting started it'd be a story about
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
their first business off the off the
ground if you look at books like the go
Giver
um Bob berg a friend of the channel it's
it's a parable right they're teaching
through
uh a narrative that doesn't actually
exist it's not a real character but
you're learning through those stories so
what is a story if you don't have any
actual examples or clients you can share
and then your last point is is Hope
give me hope make me feel hope uh make
me feel like it's possible make me feel
like I'm not alone make me feel like
where I'm at right now doesn't have to
be where I'm going to finish uh it makes
a huge huge difference because if you've
now taken me on this journey of you've
connected with me emotionally you've
you've shown me that you know what
you're talking about and that I can get
through it you've shown me examples and
results of other people who've done it
and you've done it as well and then you
leave with an inspirational message of
hope that that it's possible for me as
well you're giving people an arc that
it's people are going through these 10
posts they're way more likely to want to
work with you and so this can help as a
structure give you Clarity over the
content to create for your accounts and
I would apply this for all of my
accounts I would apply this for every
single platform that you create an
account on and then stop the goal here
is not to be the thought leader content
producer making making pieces of content
every single day getting out there this
is the fast pass to Freedom this this is
now we're going to start doing Outreach
the goal here is I want if people come
to your account to see you as the expert
next step is how do I get people to come
to my account but you got to give them
something on your account that makes you
seem credible and I want to work with
you hire you contact you take the next
step with you right it's worth spending
time on all of these uh normally when
I'm when I'm talking about making
content on the thought leadership side I
say don't worry so much about production
quality don't worry about having the
perfect words each time just get it out
there these ones it's worth treated like
a marketing brochure it's worth spend a
little bit more time on not necessarily
from having a camera crew come in and
film you and making it perfect but even
from the angle of just you being
prepared you not just throwing up your
first take you really spending time on
each to go over it because this is now
going to do all the heavy lifting for us
once we get people coming to our page so
how do we actually get people to see our
account
you reach out and there's two key ways
search and hashtags and depending on the
platform you're looking at uh some you
can search just for keywords if you go
to YouTube you can Search keywords you
can see what people are going through uh
hashtags are almost on every platform
Instagram you can't search you can only
go through hashtags or your searching is
through hashtags and you're looking for
people who are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with right your
purpose comes to your pain the people
who are going to help are the people who
currently are who you used to be the
great thing about social media is that
people are sharing all the time people
are sharing what they're going through
they're sharing what they're struggling
with they're sharing what they what
their inner demons are they're sharing
they're sharing it so you're looking for
the people who are talking about the
thing that you can help with for example
in in the book I talk about uh a guy
named Michael who helped me overcome my
concussion and we created a template for
him to say hey look for people who are
talking about concussions on Instagram
look at people who are posting because
when you get a concussion a lot of
people what they're going to do is
they're going to post Instagram
and most of the time people are just
posting to to get support from their
friends uh and sometimes to complain
right but if you're there reaching out
for help you're saying hey I know what
you're going through I've been through
that myself I want to help I've got
ideas for you that might be able to help
you what are they going to do next
is that how that's interesting this is
the only person reaching out to me uh
they're gonna go check out your account
what are they going to say in your
account they're going to see an amazing
picture an amazing bio and 10 pieces of
amazing content that we just spent all
this time working on right so the idea
is every day we're going to reach out to
people every day we're going to reach
out to people we're going to send DMS
we're gonna we're gonna text them we're
gonna send them messages
offering hope
offering guidance offering uh what I
like to do is offer a call so what I
recommend is offering a free call with
people
and guide them through how you can help
and give them value on the call like
your point of a free call is they want
to come back and work with you again
they want to they should be asking how
much does it cost to hire you okay can I
can I bring you on as my coach can I
continue working with you somehow if
you're not getting that after a free
call then you didn't do a good enough
job on the call yet in terms of
providing value and so you keep
practicing right you keep practicing
doing more and more free calls we have
our picture we have our link we have our
bio we have our 10 pieces of content and
we stop posting content and just start
outreaching
this is the fastest way to start getting
clients to start building your business
this is an extra special topic
self-publishing versus getting an agent
publisher I've got four books two of
them these two were self-published and
that's just through Amazon this one was
with your one word was my first book my
major book that was with penguin random
house that was with a six figure Advance
uh and the typical publishing deal and
then built the serve was it's almost a
hybrid so we did build the serve with
Mel Robbins label uh who she published
the five second rule with and it's it's
a hybrid in that it's it was no Advance
on this one but much bigger royalties
so typically with a publisher you get
you might get an event you might not
depends on how big your your list is and
your audience is
but you get paid very little for every
book that's sold here's I'm betting more
on myself and so less well zero on the
advance compared to six figures on this
one and I get paid more for every book
that I sell so let's talk about how to
pick self-publishing versus publishing
to help you make the best decision it
starts off with what are your goals okay
so anytime somebody's asking me there's
no one size fits all like what do you
want to accomplish so I'm going to start
by making the case for self-publishing
here's why you want to self-publish one
you have a bucket list to have a book
some people just want to have a book
it's on their bucket list or they
promise their mom they'd write a book or
they was in their High School yearbook
that they're going to have a book like
if you just want a book because it means
something to you because you want to
have something on the shelf or because
it's on your bucket list then the
easiest thing to do is just self-publish
it you don't need to go through the
hassle and headache and pain of trying
to go get a publisher just make it
yourself and poof you have your book
if you want to make money from the
actual book then you want to sell
publish because you keep just so much
more of the revenue from each book
compared to going with a major publisher
where you make basically nothing right
there's a small royalty on every single
book sold but if the goal is to make
money from the book itself
you're going to self-publish you keep
just a much much much larger percentage
if you have other goals which we'll talk
about on the publishing side there's
reasons for that but making money from
the actual book or self-publishing
if you want to use it as a funnel for
lead gen
so if you want to create a book it's
fast to set up you then use that to then
get into your funnel to then get into
your coaching to get into your products
to then get into whatever you ultimately
have to sell you have a funnel attached
to it
you'll get a much lower cost with your
own book self-published and you will
going with the publisher so you get your
book for cheaper so it's easier to send
out to people it costs you less to start
building your funnel at that front end
compared to if you get a book with a
publisher
so this is if you've got your sequence
worked out and you know you know your
entry-level product and then your next
level product and then your coaching and
in your Mastermind or whatever that
looks like for you at least having
thoughts of a roadmap a book can be a
great first step in and self-publish
gets you at a great price you get it out
quickly
one of the uh biggest Pains of
publishing is it takes like a year to
get the book out
it's a giant pain
it's other people critiquing you it's
it's slow as anything it takes you a
while to write it and anybody who's gone
through the writing process you know how
long it can take to ride and rewrite and
research and edit and all that stuff but
then when you're when it's finally done
it's like okay I'm ready here we go and
then it's another year before the book
actually comes out just because of how
long Publishers take to go through their
machine so if you want to get something
out you know if it's if it's May right
now and you want something out this year
it's not going to happen with a
publisher
so now we're already talking next year
if you want about this here you're
self-publishing you get it out super
fast
you get to be in complete control
so another frustration with any bit of
creative work is the critique to say no
don't don't do that don't put in that
chapter don't call it this I don't like
the name of your book that's not gonna
sell very well and it's it's crazy how
little research a lot of the the
organizations do a lot of the publishing
companies do
um when I was picking my cover or when I
was picking the title it's all based off
of their feel there's no Market data
there's no testing with people it's
really just whoever you're dealing with
do they like the concept or not and sure
they have some industry experience so
it's not like a total newbie opinion but
uh it's not it's never based off of what
the audience is actually asking for
needs and they have they have very
little knowledge about the audience that
you're going after so if you want to be
in complete control if you don't want to
have uh somebody telling you what colors
to use what font to use what what layout
to use what Graphics to use what to call
it any of that stuff then
self-publishing is the way to go
you own the rights which is a huge deal
so you can do whatever you want with it
now I've you can negotiate some rights
into your deals if you're working with
the publisher so for example I own the
YouTube rights the social media rights
for my books so I could just release the
whole book on YouTube or on Instagram or
on clubhouse if I wanted to
because I own the rights because they
don't really Publishers haven't really
caught up to that yet we're not thinking
what you're going to put a book on
YouTube
okay sure whatever here you go right
um so you get to own the rights and do
whatever you want with it in the future
so this is the case for self-publishing
these are the reasons why you want to
sell publish okay
publisher why to go with a publisher
what is the reason so one bestseller
list if that means something to you this
is something that's never meant much to
me because you can game the system so
easily to get on a bestseller list
people
literally just buy their way on to
bestseller lists and the way that they
do it which nobody talks about but
movement makers Insider knowledge let's
let's share what happens like how does
somebody get number one status what they
do is they drop the price for one day or
on Amazon it's it's by uh hour they drop
the price of the ebook version to one
cent
so for one hour for one day they dropped
the price to one cent They then send
tons of people you can hire services to
do this whether it's your own email list
but they have a whole bunch of people
with email lists that then just say go
buy this book for one cent
ebook and then it blows up off the
charts boom you're a bestseller and then
the next hour drops back down and and
your you know time when the sun is gone
but you can say I'm a bestseller so if
if you if you want that just because it
adds some credibility or means something
to you then it's it's a lot easier to do
it with a publisher than
um than on your own
uh Prestige and branding there is still
some cachet to having a published book
versus something that you self-published
it's dramatically dropping this is one
of the biggest fights that I got into
with my agents like you need a book
every need the book ever need a book why
do we need a book you need a book to get
on stage you need a book to to get
Partnerships you need a book to open
doors like Steve I can open doors with
my YouTube channel
I don't I don't need a book anymore it's
not that books can't help you do that
but there's lots of ways to do that if
you had a big YouTube audience you can
open doors if you had a big Clubhouse
audience there's people who are building
up on clubhouse right now who six months
you've never heard of and they're
getting
Grant Cardone into their rooms and
they're getting Jay Shetty into their
rooms and they're getting they become
they're they're they've opened the doors
they're now somebody just because of the
three months of investment they made
onto Clubhouse so Prestige and branding
can be there it's just dramatically
dropping it used to be the only way or
one of the only ways now there's tons of
ways to be able to build your brain but
if that again means something to you
then publish book still has a little bit
of cachet
editing support
was super helpful of all the things that
a publisher
what you think a publisher helps with
most of them most of the things they
don't but editing was actually really
helpful
so on the editing side I was making
typos I can't believe how many typos I
made
I write it out and I'm I feel like I'm a
pretty good writer you know and not
somebody who failed English class I'm a
pretty good writer and then I would read
the whole thing
and and catch some typos but then I give
to them like oh wow you made so many wow
I can't believe how many typos I made
it's crazy I even gave it to my friends
and family to go through and read give
it to 30 people each time to go through
and read and they caught some typos but
then still the editors caught typos
so and there's still one typo in your
one word that made it through that
everybody missed
uh so it's a little sad the editing
support is very real and I think if you
if you can't afford it then you hire net
if you're gonna sell publish you hire an
editor or even just try to find who is
your uh do you have a friend who's just
really really detail-oriented and great
at editing who can help you you know
lend lend an extra pair of eyes to it
um next formatting support
formatting is formatting especially for
ebooks really sucks you know if you're
if you're creating your book and you you
make it in a Word document and then you
try to translate that to an Amazon
format especially with ebooks where
there's no where it's like infinite
scroll it's such a giant pain now I I
gave it to somebody on my team for the
self-published stuff I said Ray just
figure it out
because it was driving me nuts and Ray
loves new challenges but that took a
couple weeks of his of his life just
trying to figure out how to format the
book to be on Amazon especially for the
ebook and when you go with the publisher
they just take care of all of that stuff
easily for you be in the bookstores
again it's less and less and less
important most bookstores are either
closing down or are supplementing you
walk into a bookstore and a lot of them
are half furniture stores or lifestyle
stores and selling vases and flowers and
a bunch of other stuff so it's not as
important but if you want to get into a
bookstore the Publishers have the
relationships it's not impossible as a
self-published book but it's almost
impossible as a self-published book to
get into bookstores so again that means
something to you if you want to
roll into your Barnes and Nobles with
your family and take a picture you know
view with the book here on the shelves
uh then you have to go with the
publisher
today guys we have a super super super
important topic when to push
versus when to break and this is a
really important one because
I think uh
we have moments where we are our best we
have moments where we are showing up
where we are motivated we're inspired
where we're doing our thing where we
know that what we're doing is important
where we feel the impact maybe you join
movement makers and you've got a lot of
inspiration from the session maybe
somebody left you a great comment but
then there's going to be days when you
wake up and you don't feel like it and
you don't have the energy and it's not
as high and you you have that voice
inside your head that says
tomorrow do it do it tomorrow right it's
okay you deserve a break you've been
working too hard
what do you do when that voice comes in
when all your friends tell you to take
it easy to relax and take a break I have
a rule
where I want to spend 95 of my time
pushing harder and five percent of my
time giving myself a break because there
are definitely some times we actually
really do need a break we need to take
care of yourself where you need to relax
we've actually pushed too hard and
that's okay but most of the time I think
you need to push harder I think that's
the mindset of high Achievers and I'm
going to break down today some of the
stories just my own experience you can
learn from as well as some strategies
you can use to help you identify when to
push harder and when to break so first
thing I'm going to talk about here how
did the side between pushing versus
breaking
pass the pillow test
so let's dive in so again 95 push five
percent break this is my own internal
metric this is what I tell myself
95 of the time when I'm feeling low
energy tired don't feel like doing it
have have every excuse in the world not
to do it every reason everybody else
left me off the hook 95 of the time me
Evan Carl Michael emotionally the voice
in my head is
go do it
you have to go do it this becomes an
identity thing
this is who I want to be Evan Carmichael
at his best self is the guy who's off
pushing for one more
say no that little voice in my head and
then five percent is to take a break
take it easy it's okay to rest right uh
you can figure out what the numbers are
for you but for achievers
you guys got big movements ahead of you
it should lean more towards the push
than the break
so let me talk to you about Tuesday
we've been going through some crazy
times here at the Carmichael household
uh we just came back from a trip we went
out to uh to Kelowna our first family
trip in the past two years which is
which is amazing uh there's no Corona
out there at all so everybody's around
no masks in uh indoor dining all of it
we're here in Toronto's a lot of still
issues you can't do indoor dining we're
in masterfield we're going out there but
we come back here
I decided I want to redo my office and
redo my bedroom uh and do floors I want
new floors so you probably can't see
them from this angle because I moved my
desk and it's a little chaotic but we
got brand new floors in the office it
wasn't ready it was supposed to be ready
on Monday
we got the wrong floors it didn't work
so Tuesday was a disaster
Tuesday is normally my YouTube filming
day
okay
we can't sleep on our bedroom on Monday
night because they put half the floors
and they got to take them out I can't do
anything in our second bedroom because
it's full of all the junk from the first
bedroom and I can't do anything in my
third bedroom which is my office because
the floors are all ripped up here too so
we take our bed and put it down in the
kitchen the only spot and so we slept in
the kitchen
Monday night
okay Tuesday Morning Comes Around I had
a terrible sleep I'm still jet lagged
Nina's got an early morning acupuncture
apartment and Tuesday is my espresso
video guys I gotta go film espresso I
usually Drive Lena to wherever she needs
to go she goes and does her stuff and I
film videos in the car it's been our
tradition
she wakes up I am dead tired
and she said I'm gonna I'm gonna go you
sleep in a little bit I'll come back and
get you in a couple hours
this is the point when that little voice
really matters
because in my head I'm thinking I'm
tired I'm jet lagged
she's gonna come back in two hours and
I'll be able to film that anyway I can
still get it done right we we create a
logical reason how we can still follow
through I can still get it done
I'm sleeping in the kitchen
I deserve this I just came back this is
crazy but then literally 10 seconds
later it's like no I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming I get up we rush
out and then I go and film videos and
instead of just making usual uh espresso
day I'll make seven videos I made 15.
just because just because that's what
Evan Carmichael does right and not that
I'm some superhero like it's something
that's been built
every time you have that little voice
inside your head that says Nah you know
you shouldn't do it like no
there's no reason why I can't
and then go a little bit harder push a
little bit more now I went a little
crazy because I was really in the zone
and I love when I'm in the zone I love
staying in the zone as much as possible
so instead of doing seven I finished off
the ten that were on my list and then I
asked for five more and then finished
those five as well
come on Evan Carmichael let's go right
and this is for for all of you the same
thing you have that little voice that
tells you you can't do it gives you all
the reasons why you can't
and then you show yourself that you can
and not just that you can do that thing
but you can do more
and what it does is start to shift the
identity
it starts to take away that little voice
in your head so that it doesn't have to
take you I used to lose an entire day I
never lost weeks or months right but I
would lose an entire day if some one
little thing happened that that derailed
me the whole day would be gone like okay
I'll figure it out tomorrow
the goal is to try to get that to as
shorter window as possible
so instead of I take an entire day for
you to bounce back it's you know a
couple hours to then an hour to then
half an hour to then five minutes to
then you know 15 seconds you know stuff
is going to happen
the the answer is not to avoid all of
the pains in life stuff is going to
happen to you it's how do you react to
them and then get back on track
showing yourself that you're the person
who does it
so I want to share a recent example
because that just happened Tuesday the
the most painful examples back in 2019
when I broke my neck and I had a goal of
going live every day on Instagram I said
on my tour I'm gonna go live every
single day on Instagram every day 90
days every day I'm going live on
Instagram no matter what little did I
know I was going to be in the hospital
with a concussion and break my neck in
two spots but that no matter what
made me want to do it
and this was me I broke my neck on
Nina's birthday March 15th is Nina's
birthday and we broke my neck and was in
the hospital and I said I need to go
live and the doctor was like you can't
go live and Nina's like you're crazy
what are you doing like no no I said I
was gonna go live every day I can't even
see the phone at this point right I've
got a concussion I don't know what's
happening on the screen but even if it's
for 60 seconds
I'm gonna go live and most of my live
streams were an hour long right
I don't know how long this one ended up
being it was probably a couple minutes I
just gave people a quick update it looks
like I'm dying
so Doug watler who's a movement maker
and long time you know friend uh took
this screenshot and posted his Instagram
it's like Doug I look like I'm dead I
mean he took it in black and white for
whatever reason I wasn't filming in
black and white and posted it but what
I'm I'm I'm happy and I see you know
Adam Duran who gave a thumbs up in the
chat here on this picture uh who's also
now Muka makers welcome board Adam this
might have been might have been crazy uh
might have been too stupid
but I'm proud of it it was probably the
worst live stream I've ever done I don't
know what I said it was probably very
incoherent just telling people what
happened
and then I'm gonna be okay
but it was likely my worst live stream
of all time but one of the ones that I'm
most proud of because there was every
reason why I couldn't do it and then I
still went and did it right
so fast forward March 29th so two weeks
later I'm back to filming videos
now they're not the most coherent videos
I'm not the best on camera I'm wearing
this neck brace I've got this giant scab
on my forehead right I look at myself
how many times have you looked at
yourself and like I can't make videos
today because what because my hair is a
little bit out of place
looking at you Alex
because because I gained a little bit of
weight because whatever right I'm
sitting here with a neck brace on
there's Alex taking his Hab out there we
go you know with this giant scab on my
forehead like let's go right and I had
that guys I had that voice too it's like
I can't make a video with this crazy
thing on my forehead with this neck
brace on I can't even fit into my
clothes I'm wearing I might be naked
under this I'm not sure but I may I
might have a t-shirt on I couldn't lift
my arms to get anything on I couldn't
put my my usual believe hoodie on so I
put on a jacket
this is an Arizona or something this is
like super warm
but I'm wearing a jacket
start making videos because I had that
voice in my head again telling me you
can't do this look at you you're a mess
everybody would every who would not
understand right like everybody would
understand if I didn't make content
given what happened but I don't want
that like that's the standard I was on a
walk with with Nina this morning taking
the dogs up before coming here and she's
like your standards are just way up here
this is a normal person and your
standards are on the sky it's like yes
exactly that's what we want and by you
raising your standards you lift
everybody else up around you as well so
it's not that I don't have these voices
I still have those voices telling me I
can't do it and and all the reasons why
I can't it's fighting that voice every
single day
by April uh the scab was gone uh I still
can't fit into my hoodie so I I went to
the store I was tired of filming in just
my one jacket so we went to a store and
we bought this giant like double XL Nike
sweater
[Music]
the only thing I could fit into on a
day-to-day basis so you can see it there
I've gained some weight like look at me
I'm barely moving guys my my pillow's
behind me I'm in so much pain every day
we're continuing the tour look at how
much look at my face look at how much
weight I've been so now I'm
self-conscious about my weight I've just
gained 15 pounds because I'm lying on on
a couch all day because I can't move I
can't film now I can't film being this
fat Evan
again Voice to my head no I have to do
it now because that was in my head now I
have to do it because that was the
reason
I refuse to not make content because of
that voice I refuse to play small
because of that voice right could I take
a break yes is this where I'm proud of
myself for taking a break no so I'm
gonna make videos
and then fast forward to may now I'm I'm
healing a little bit more you can see I
lost some weight on my face if you go
back uh I'm at home now I can fit into
my shirts again I'm still wearing the
neck brace still healing but still
making content
still making content my health card we
have a photo health card here in Ontario
and when we got back I had to renew my
health card because my wallet was stolen
in LA on our trip and we'd get to the
place to take the picture and I'm
wearing my neck brace and he's like
don't you want to take your neck brace
off for for the camera because this is
going to be on your health card for the
next five years have you like scrunched
up here with this neck brace so I'm like
I've got that on my health card for the
next five years like I showed up
to take my picture that we all get
self-conscious of in my neck brace when
I could have taken it off just because
right like it's that daily constant
attacking of that little voice inside
your head telling you all the reasons
why that you can't win
okay so I filmed throughout the whole
thing there wasn't a time that I that I
took a day off on filming now in 2019
October
my family my family dog died Toby and uh
he he passed away we put him down he had
really bad cancer he was struggling for
a long time and
um they passed away on on a Tuesday
which was our my filming day
it was the morning and it was my family
all there and um my dad and I stayed in
the room with with him while you know
they gave him the final injection and
everybody else left and it was super
emotional and I just
I couldn't imagine going home and
filming
you know and so I uh I told
Christina my editor let's do some
mashups we still have to get videos up
but let's do some content and let's just
explain it at the beginning that I I
skipped the filming day you know so we
wrote this Toby my family dog my
family's dog passed away from cancer
this week I didn't do my regular and
stressful filming I hope you understand
I Love You Toby still can't believe
you're gone thank you for an amazing 11
years and I'm still kind of getting a
little
choked up just looking at it
but I was okay with um with not filming
on that day
you know I was okay with it like this is
where I would film through a broken neck
I would film through everything else but
but um
you know for me this was the moment
where like okay in the past however many
years this is the time that I'm not I'm
not filming and I'm okay with that
now for those of you who have dogs maybe
you get what I'm saying for those of you
you might think I'm crazy
um
that's okay too
it's not judging somebody else's reasons
it's are you proud of yourself
for why you didn't do it I'm okay that I
didn't film that week we still got
videos up I'm okay with it
that was a five percent
right 95 push five percent break I'm
okay with that five percent being a
break
movement makers great to see you again
okay so we're on to something
pretty exciting today this was an
interesting topic that I think really
holds a lot of people back you guys
especially for Achievers because you
guys know
you guys know you're capable of more and
you know that you're you're pushing
other people to do great things and at
the same time you're not doing all the
things that you should be doing right is
that does that relate it's like you know
that you could be doing more
you know you know that you're doing more
than your friends and the people around
you but how many days you go maybe even
days or weeks in a row where it's like
okay I I played small I was afraid
I didn't do what I should have right and
we beat ourselves up and and the point
isn't to just lay more beats on you the
point is to be able to make progress and
so today's theme which I'm super excited
by is how to build the resilience
mindset to overcome obstacles and get
back up quickly let's dive in one of the
things I get asked the most when I do
podcasts interviews uh I'm on somebody's
show Clubhouse they say what are your
non-negotiables you know what's the
thing that you have to do every single
day or what's your morning routine and
what what is non-negotiable has to
happen all the time
and I don't really have anything that's
absolutely non-negotiable I think the
closest thing is connection to Nina
if I look at our relationship over the
past decade I don't know that there's
been a single day that I haven't
connected with Nina
now obviously when I'm home that's easy
but when I'm traveling and I'm away
every day at least I'm checking in once
just to see how she's doing even on the
craziest of crazy days but apart from
that
there's nothing that has to be every
single day and I think one of the
challenges that we come up with for
ourselves is we feel like we have to be
perfect we have perfectionists in the
house are you perfectionist because I
know I am I'm a recovering perfectionist
you know I lost that 40 million dollar
deal when I was 20 because I was trying
to be perfect and I still want things to
be perfect the problem is when we don't
hit our mark
what we end up doing is nothing
you know when we don't actually go and
accomplish what we want we don't want to
feel like a loser we don't want to feel
less than and so we just spend our time
on something else instead of actually
starting to build momentum for the
dreams that we have so
I found this awesome graphic of the
perfect morning routine you know like
wake up before you have to and go make a
cup your happy beverage spend time doing
something you enjoy say something nice
about yourself go it's how I get some
sun eat a good breakfast be kind to
yourself open your windows wipe write
down how you can best meet your needs
for the day then we have this this
concept of what a perfect one routine is
and that's great but this might take two
hours and we don't always follow through
perfectly I am never a hundred percent
on my morning routine every month if you
look at my my morning routine and what I
do every month there's I don't think
there's been a single month where I'm
hitting in 100 of the time
and that's normal
and that's fine and that's okay
it's not expecting to be perfect but
it's expecting to do the best that we
can
because life will throw circumstances at
you uh life will throw obstacles at you
and what we often do when we're trying
to be perfect again is we're either
perfect or we're nothing
and that's a problem and there are a few
days where we can be perfect there are a
few days where you can get your perfect
days down
but then what happens when you come up
against some obstacle
what often happens too much even for
Achievers we're talking Achievers here
we're not talking to people who have no
goals no aspirations no dreams achievers
will still do nothing
because it can't be perfect
and so I want to start to
blur that line a little bit so it's not
perfect or zero that we're always trying
to do the best we can so we're proud of
our effort
I saw this and I love that if the
version of you from five years ago could
see you right now they'd be so proud
keep going
and this is often what we need to remind
ourselves of when you when you feel like
you're not perfect when you feel like
you're not getting results when you feel
like you let yourself down your family
down your community down the people
around you down
that's the time to reflect back and say
hey where was I five years ago look at
all of you five years ago where were you
come on now
compared to what you're doing right now
the the projects you're working on the
adventures you're involved in the
communities you're part of the you from
five years ago would not recognize do
you right now today
and sometimes we have to remind
ourselves of that
when we fall off of our perfect horse
how do you get back up quickly right
this is the theme of the day
you remind yourself of the journey that
you've been on
because what we need to do is get back
to the consistency
so you get back on the horse and keep
going how do we get back on the horse
this will help
look at the journey look at how much
you've grown look at how much you've
done look at how much you've
accomplished look at all the lives that
you've impacted the people that you've
helped how much you've learned and grown
and gotten better
because it helps to get rid of the pity
party that I'm not perfect now I didn't
do it so now I'm zero
it's not zero or a hundred right 97 is a
great score
let's remind ourselves of that and keep
going because the consistency is going
to be the thing that gets you to where
you go
it's not the perfect
it's the consistency that we'll get to
where you need to go
Terry I'm definitely in a different
space from five years ago I love it
Pablo in the house says hola
Marcus recovering perfectionist listen I
think everybody here is a recovering
perfectionist
I think Achievers are perfectionists
we want we know it can be better we want
it to be better
and so this is how we stop getting in
our own way
it's a great quote I came across from
Cassie Stevens who's um our teacher
she's a she's a creator
she said we see kids start to become
perfectionists and we see them start to
struggle we need to guide the way for
them
and keep the joy in art
and this is a great message for kids but
it's also a great message for you
it's a great message for you like how
many adults how many thought leaders how
many creators how much great art of
yours has not come out because you were
struggling with being a perfectionist
I know there's lots of things that I
didn't release
especially early on because I was afraid
it wasn't good enough it wasn't perfect
that would be critiqued that I could do
better
and as a result I didn't release it
this isn't just a kid's thing this is
this is a human thing and again
especially for achievers
because we want to achieve we want to we
want to win we want to get the gold
medal you know we want the results
and we're afraid to release something
that doesn't get the results
but that becomes the game because a lot
of the things that you create
you never know if it's actually going to
win or not a lot of my best videos I
would all of the best videos on my
channel I would never have pegged to say
that's the one that's going to win never
and a lot of the ones that I love the
most
didn't do well he was like wait really
you guys don't like that video come on
now I love that one
so it makes a really big difference you
just get your art out there
to stop judging to stop critiquing and
just release and what I find really
helpful with this is
tomorrow you release again
and the next day you release again and
the next day you release again so it's
not so much pressure on this one thing
being perfect
because you're going to create another
one and another one and another one and
another one we need to put the art
back into your content
okay when you overthink it and try to
make it perfect all the time you suck
the creativity art out of it creativity
is messy art is messy
it's not going to be perfect at the
beginning
that's the whole point and we struggle
we struggle with that
so what helps is just not expecting to
be perfect don't expect it to be
especially at the beginning
don't expect it to be perfect that's why
we do the 100 video challenge I want you
to expect to suck at the beginning like
just expect to suck
Release Yourself of the burden of it
being fantastic expect it to be terrible
expect to look back on your first video
and be embarrassed
but after you get through 10 after you
get through 20 after you get through 50.
after you get to 100 you look back and
say holy cow I got so much better people
who've gone through the 100 video
challenge even a couple videos in 10
videos in
start to say wow I'm already so much
better
I made it too big a project and as a
result I did nothing
so stop expecting to be perfect sing
your own song because you can sing Alan
says five years ago I had not met Evan I
appreciate appreciate you man progress
over Perfection says dude I love it you
can't mess up art because you can always
paint over it and do it again
on on so right now
I had to remind myself of that going
into what I'm doing right now because
I've been with my son for the past few
weeks and we've got
a little more time together before he
starts to go back to school and I wanted
to really make it count and as a result
I have done
very little on my business usual stuff I
got way ahead on YouTube so content is
coming out got way ahead on Instagram
all that stuff so content is coming up
but I'm not doing my Ig lives I'm not
doing
uh any podcasts any interviews I'm not
meeting with my team I'm not doing all
the stuff that I usually do that I that
I love to do that I don't see it as work
you know when I meet with Alex or Drew
on a Monday it's not like oh
man gotta meet that Alex guy
granted I don't see it as work this is
what I love to do this is great
but I also wanted to be intentional with
my time while Hayden is here
and as a result uh I knew I wouldn't be
able to keep up on my usual commitments
and so Angela sent this amazing message
to me on my DMs on Instagram that I
wanted to share it's like okay I get it
I get it man believe nation is missing
you you are missed on Instagram 2PM is
so boring you are loved so glad you're
enjoying your family time everyone looks
really happy so good to see you love you
all and she's saying that because two
o'clock Eastern I would go live on
Instagram
two o'clock Eastern I go live on
Instagram uh it's either me with a guest
or me sometimes movement makers pop in
and we do a round table which is super
fun where I just coach people live it's
I never know what's going to happen on a
Tuesday all right sorry Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Friday doing my Instagram
lives but
I'm not doing it I haven't done it in
three weeks
Mr consistency hasn't done it in three
weeks
because I'm trying to be intentional and
spend that time with my son so apart
from movement makers brand lytics
um I'm not doing any of my usual
commitments and so some people Angel is
very warm and loving this is a great
message some people aren't as warm or
loving some people are more attacking
and critical it's like yo where are you
where's where's the Instagram lives how
when do I get my turn it's like come on
I'm I'm doing something else right now
um and so I'm not
trying to be perfect
I'm not going in thinking I can do
everything but I'm trying to be
intentional with the time that I'm
spending
so don't expect to be perfect if you
want to watch the full version of this
video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join